madame monsieur bonsoir la principale
information de ce samedi nous vient
encore d'Allemagne de l'Est où après 45
années de statut quo la situation évolue
non plus de semaine en semaine mais
pratiquement de jour en jour et tout
peut arriver pourquoi pas demain la
destruction du mur qui sépare les deux
Allemagnes en effet aujourd'hui la RDA a
officiellement autorisé ses
ressortissants à quitter le pays sans
formalité en passant par la
Tchécoslovaquie et l'ambassade
d'Allemagne fédérale à Prague nous
allons y revenir tout de suite mais dans
le même temps aujourd'hui encore à
Berlin est une immense foule s'est
rassemblée entre 500000 et 1 million de
personnes pour réclamer la liberté de la
presse et encore plus de réforme le
nouveau numéro installement monsieur
krens ne parvient pas visiblement à
reprendre la situation en main malgré
l'annonce de nouveaux changements à
Berlin notre correspondant Philippe
Rochot 500000 manifestants dans le
centre de Berlin Est c'est la plus
gigantesque manifestation depuis le
renversement d'Eric coneker les 600
journalistes et artistes
des berlis dans la r dem d'abord la
libre expression artique la liberté de
la pre que les journaux et la télévision
s'eng à dire la vérité au public ils
organisê le service d'ordre la police
faisit discrète nintervenant pas quand
des arti le geste fatigu
d'unch et qui d'un cancer du
pancréasour
P beaucoup de gens ne savent pas ici ce
que peut être la liberté il faut faire
plus de place à la critique dans les
journaux et à la
télévision mais aujourd'hui vous arrivez
par exemple à écrire ce que vous
voulez
j'ess sous la pression de la foule
évalué à 500000 personnes sur Alexander
plat le pouvoir a d accepter le débat
affronter les ouvriers les étudiants
pour cette manifestation les dirigeants
du parti les écrivains avaient chacun 5
minutes pour expliquer ce qu'ils
entendaient faire de la liberté
d'expression mais déjà des changements
se dessinent dans ce domaine comme le
constate ce professeur de français il y
a des choses qui ont
changé depuis peu ça vaut la peine à
nouveau de lire les journaux et je crois
que beaucoup de
gens profitent ou utiliseent beaucoup de
leur journée beaucoup de temps de leur
journée pour lire les journaux c'est un
fait qui ne s'est jamais vu avant et
même pour voir
les les actualités télévisées du soir
les gens se pressent pour pour voir
quelque chose de
nouveau le plus chahuté au cours de
cette
manifestationabski un homme du parti qui
se présente pourtant comme un homme de
dialogue il a échappé
annoncé par le numéro 1 est
allemandon en liant 5 membres du PO
bureau à la veille de cette
manifestation
on a tenté de donner satisfaction à une
partie des manifestants qui réclamaient
des hommes nouveaux mais les Allemands
de l'Est devront attendre mercredi
prochain la réunion exceptionnelle du
Comité central du Parti communiste est
allemand pour savoir s'ils ont été
entendus